Have you ever heard a word for the first
time a word like,
I dunno corpuscular,
which by the way is an adjective
describing twilight,
and then the next day you see
corpuscular again in a novel and then
you see it again the next day in your
biology textbook and you start to
wonder,
how is it possible that I've gone the
first 20 years of my life without ever
seeing the word corpuscular and now in
the last week,
I've seen crepuscular three times.
I know I've experienced this strong
feeling of coincidence before many
times,
and there's a name for it.
It's called the Baader Meinhof
phenomenon.
Nobody really knows why it's called
that.
The baader Meinhof group was a late 20th
century leftwing millet infection from
west Germany.
It's likely that the person who gave it
that name just happened to be awash in
coincidentally baader Meinhof
references.
The more scientific name for this
phenomenon is the frequency illusion,
and it's just another example of our old
friend,
the cognitive bias at work.
See,
when we see something for the first time
and then many times directly thereafter,
it can lead us to believe that there's a
greater synchronicity at work in the
world around us.
Perhaps it's an artifact of determinism,
the feeling that everything happens for
a reason.
The coincidence we feel is just too
astronomically unlikely,
but of course the truth is that most
bordering on all things don't happen for
a reason despite our intuition that they
do,
and yet it's just that intuition
activated in the Baader Meinhof
phenomenon that gives us an interesting
look into the machinery of the mind.
Our brains are essentially pattern
recognizing superheroes,
able to find meaning in countless pieces
of data,
whether it's our ability to see words in
a newspaper word search or to work out
through fine mathematics,
the natural laws of the universe for
this reason,
stimuli which are excited sort of sit
and wait at the fore of the brain for
similar stimuli with which to identify a
pattern.
In other words,
you may have seen the word corpuscular a
number of times in your life,
but your brain just wasn't interested.
The frequency illusion is augmented by
two other phenomenon.
First,
the recency effect,
a cognitive bias that inflates the
importance of recent stimuli or
observations,
and second,
by the confirmation bias,
which in this case is precisely your
belief that you're seeing this new thing
all over the place and the frequency
illusion can become confirmation bias
when our passive experience of
repeatedly seeing a new thing turns into
an active search for still more examples
of the magic that summons,
but what's more interesting to me about
this phenomenon is not the coincidence
is that you think you see,
but all the patterns that are zipping by
in your day to day life that you don't
register at all.
The baader Meinhof illusion proves that
we only see the things that we're
looking out for.
This can be bad in the case of
confirmation bias,
but it also goes to show how ignorance
can be maintained through a lack of
active learning.
The more you prime your mind by reading
and writing to see new patterns,
the more reality will unfold before you
as an extraordinary mechanism of natural
laws.
The more humanity will show itself to be
an empathetic and beautiful mess of self
delusions and cognitive biases.
I could end this video like everybody
else who writes articles about this
subject does.
By saying that you'll probably see the
Baader Meinhof phenomenon again sometime
soon,
but of course those people weren't
talking about the Baader Meinhof
phenomenon.
Merely as a ruse to get you to take more
notice of the word crepuscular
[inaudible].
That's what I was doing.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
Sorry I was a little bit late last week
with the video.
I was traveling all over God's creation.
I just didn't have the time to finish
it.
I was wondering if you like the
understanding art house feature that I
did last week.
It's a little bit different,
but I was thinking of doing it as a
series sprinkled in between other
videos.
Tell me what you think.
Also,
I sort of like putting out the video on
Monday.
I might continue to do that instead of
Friday.
I don't know.
I just feel like it gives more
opportunity for people to see it.
The weekend people usually check out.
Let me know what you think about that as
well.
Follow me on Tumbler and twitter.
Discussed this video in the comments and
post this on reddit.
If you have any heart at all for me and
continuing to do this and I love you so
much for that,
I will see you next time.